emerging from the shadow of covid the
nhs beacon symbolizing more than just a
royal honor
a celebration at tameside hospital but
also a reminder of what's been lost it's
um i mean it's a great representation
because it's made from the old hospital
beds and obviously it's right in front
of our estate and yeah it is probably a
symbol of ashton really uplifting i
think after the
last couple of years that everybody's
been through with the pandemic
it just
meant so much it's coming from a
different background and this is really
really exciting for me in fact i told
look i'm actually being this because
it's really really good because
it's very uplifting because
we've been through a lot
during the company period we're having
like this it's such a
really exciting day
weir was a respiratory and lung cancer
specialist at north manchester general
he died in 2020 from covid the start of
the jubilee marks three years since he
received an honor from the queen you
must miss him terribly yeah massively
every day i live with it every day and
like i said he's not just me
there's thousands of other people as
well that are still losing people
through covid as well you know people
that have had cancer treatments delayed
and stuff like that
that that's tough for them i think if we
can remember obviously what everyone's
been through
over the past two years but especially
the people that were
affected more by by covering and stuff
like that yeah
the beacon was built out of old and
broken hospital beds welded together by
students like kane into the shape of a
crown
before he even um told us about it it
was
we didn't know we didn't have a clue
what we have to do or anything like that
but to do something like for the queen
it was just it's just good and it's just
like you feel good about it
the nhs often referred to as the jewel
in the crown of the nation a fitting
tribute to the queen's reign but also
its own recent history illuminated now
more than ever adele robinson sky news
tameside